>>Nicole: So, we're getting to the end
of our festivals of light unit.
>>In this project, the students
explore different cultures
and world religions.
>>All of you have chosen a festival
to learn about, to research.
And now that we're getting
to the end of this unit,
we're going to do a
little bit of reflection.
>>All along, we do talk about things,
but I don't necessarily say
why exactly we're doing this
because I want it to
come together for them.
>>And so, your question to think
about in your journal is why
do you think we are learning
about different festivals
of light and people
of different religious backgrounds?
>>For me, teaching tolerance
with kids is really important
and building empathy along the way...
yeah, it's part of being a
global citizen and how might
that affect the decisions we make.
>>If you're done, can you share with
us why do you think it's important
to learn about different cultures,
different religions
and things like that?
>>Student: I think we're learning
about different festivals of light
and different religious backgrounds
because if we ever met somebody
of that religion, not only do
you know some of their religions,
you would also know a
little about that somebody.
>>Nicole: Okay so, when you
have interactions with people,
you'll be able to know more about
them and be more comfortable.
>>Student: I think that it
might be because if you go
to a different country, you don't
know what will might offend them
or something.
>>Nicole: Right, that's...
you guys are getting really close.
You're really figuring this out.
We talked about this a little bit
the other day, about this phrase.
I want to see if you remember this,
that it was global competence.
Can you say that?
>>All: Global competence.
>>Nicole: Like any
kind of vocabulary,
if they have the experience,
the point of reference,
then they're able to
make that connection.
Because they've been in a
school that's really emphasizing
global competence.
>>What it means to be globally aware,
aware of what's happening
in the world.
>>When we worked on defining it
and putting terminology to it,
they made the connection right away.
A globally competent person is
something that's very important,
but taking action is a piece
of that, is how do you go out
and help other people
be globally competent.
>>And so, now it's our time
in this unit to take action.
And the way that you are
going to take action is
through your presentations.
You are doing PowerPoint
presentations to teach others.
>>They present their
festivals of light.
And they compare and contrast
it to their own culture
and whatever they celebrate.
We take action by teaching others.
We have a certain knowledge.
And now it's our responsibility to go
out and share that with other people
so that they can be exposed to the
things that we've learned about.